on va jouer au quiz première fois je
vais vous donner où ça s'est passé pour
tous ceux qui sont autour de la table et
vous allez essayer de trouver entre vous
dans la garçonnière de mon père sous
l'eau dans une piscine qui a fait ça là
première fois sous nos cieux dans une
piscine ce qui a fait ça dans le lit
d'un homme plus âgé qui a fait ça en
colonie de vacances
d'ailleurs colonies je crois qu'à
quinzaine mairie si on pouvait éviter
les fautes d'orthographe
parce que je vous le dis j'ai encore
acheté le goncourt tout à l'heure c'est
bon dans sa chambre merci à ils vont le
faire
[Applaudissements]
à
dans un show est à la fête du collège
alors moi j'ai surtout envie de savoir
qu'il a fait à la fête du collège parce
que
ah je vois qui sait la jupe je
m'attendais pas à ça alors à votre avis
qui a fait ça dans la garçonnière
on va dans la garçonnière de son père
tout simplement j'y verse gilles verdez
gênante
non c'est pas vous non mail isabelle non
non non si raymond roux thierry moreau
non non non et non non c'est pas il
n'aura non plus précis riespach oui
allez voir c'est christophe carrière
savait que le problème du dépucelage
c'est qu'il faut trouver l'endroit c'est
pas maintenant on est on est jeune voilà
en bref vous allez chez les routes ou
voies l'échec voilà il fallait se
trouvent leurs droits et et mon père qui
était assez chaud ça va durer longtemps
votre père qui est assez chaud vous
l'avez après wau une demande et je
voudrais pas très bien merci en tout cas
c'était sa 18h avec tristesse génèrent
des âpres et étaler sa copine et moi il
m'a proposé
ouais c'était rien faire avec des ados
souvent dans une piscine qui a fait ça
sous l'eau dans une piscine commandant
cousteau commandant cousteau gros mots
non vanilla nabil arabi la wii c'est
l'habitat et vous n'avez la soul au dos
mais si tu sais pas mais j'étais pas moi
sous le c'était lui qui est sous l'eau
mais ma tête a été pas sous l'eau ah
ouais vous êtes nabila où loana parce
que
le bilan est donc alors racontez nous
comment s'est passé je me rappelle plus
trop bah ouais ouais quoi c'est
lorsqu'il ya quoi mais c'était il ya
longtemps par tous en même temps s'il
vous plaît c'était comme sa maîtresse
bat ya longtemps c'est quoi la journée a
pas trop longtemps
mais vous avez quel âge vous déjà 20
jusqu à chaque fois ils songent d'agel
chaque jour hier à la mer un terrain
aujourd'hui à la vente de deux mâles va
avoir 40 et comme elle c'est un truc de
fou
le poser une question est ce que c'est
une piscine municipale certaines
piscines à vagues ménages et une piscine
d'un club med gym presque avait pas de
nofrag au début et qui en a eu à la fin
non et alors et donc c'est équivalent sg
c'est plus qu'un français à l'étranger 1
bah quoi un français apparemment leur
pas parler s'était pas marquer cela est
alors un français et quoi il était dans
le club depuis l'antiquité dans l'eau
alors mais alors j'aurai gens n'y a que
des français dans l'eau elle arrive et
doivent bien fait la france a su plaire
à tous les espagnols vous sortez les
allemands aussi je les français et alors
et donc et donc vers comme échappées
mais je sais plus quel tri pascal pascal
le grand frère
il m
j'ai pas compris pourquoi dans une
piscine mais parce que j'étais au club
mettant fin à l'accord met en bouche et
de le faire dans la piscine
j'ai reçu une note d'information
prochainement la dernière fois avec
votre femme dans la piscine n'ont jamais
vu se faire virer par un ordinateur dans
le lit moi j'ai vu avec café son tir à
l'arc ils arrivent ils ont viré banuls
ce détail est 9e et donc et lester b et
après vous être resté avec lui ou l'aï
plus jamais revu
ben si je les ai revus après être resté
qu'on m'a protégé était en vacances avec
ma mère ouais d'accord il ya du que
c'était au club même genre il ya des
activités où on est ensemble alors la
cellule at il à la ta ta ta nana allez
ola olé olé majeau appel qu'à 15 heures
il y aura nation concours de tir à l'arc
et bien sûr à 17 heures tout le monde à
prendre
[Applaudissements]
en ce moment ils sont en train
d'investir prouvé être une image très
vite c'est génial c'est une des
activités eau là j'ai fait le concours
de tir à l'arc en jeu finissaient dans
la piscine alors qu'hier tessa dans le
lit d'un homme plus âgé alors déjà la
phrase je la comprends pas il ya délit
d'un homme dans le lit d'un homme plus
âgé qui est normal et non et laura et
vous croyez n'aura été que captain igloo
d'enseignement verdez dans le lit d'un
homme plus âgé à isa isr ravel et
isabelle
c'est possible si vous
ils se connaissent bien ils se
connaissent bien cerceau alors eh ben
oui elle allait rester dans le reportage
elle verra alors comment s'était passé à
côté de passer le bac g t il pour fêter
ça allez on y va carrément à faisait
peur je me suis fait ça donc j'ai choisi
un homme qui avec kim apporter son
expérience je me suis dit comme je la
portais ma jeunesse il va être très doit
donc vous vous avez qu à la bombe a
comme j'ai passé le bac avec deux ans de
retard je n'avais bien 18 maintenant
vous avez un staff n'ont besoin car ses
19 points 6 passes et une avec l âge et
lui en avait 46 web s il est dans ma
tête je regarde là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va et on a envie de dire
chapeau l'artiste alors elle joue mieux
et il a été super doux away
quand pendant 40 ans je le mettrais
c'est exceptionnel je peux le temps
parce que j'ai bossé très vite mais
après il m'a fait et aux amandes et du
café ou une truite est totalement là
c'était georges pernoud thalassa
le gars il a sorti la sortie de truites
vous regardez ce que je te ramène et le
mec tout du mec la truite affaires
étrangères vient en service en salle de
bain qu'est-ce que j'ai ramené et alors
il vous l'a fait de privations déteste
la truite et mes amendes et le café au
lait mais tout ça a été très bien
ah ouais il s'appelait rollin une banque
il a soufflé dans quel ques et
d'ailleurs et roland
ouais ouais on le connaît on attend
c'est roland garros il n'est plus que
terre battue
[Applaudissements]
qui a fait ça en colonie de vacances
vous en colle aux vacances dans ce n'est
pas moi j'ai pas moi des moyens
moi je ne l'est pas encore fait si tu
gagnes un petit ruban submersible en
colère vacances alors racontez nous
donnons plus beaux jardins ya pas de nom
moi j'ai fait je faisais du colonie de
vacances de planche à voile et je ne
pensais pas du tout à ça et en pleine
nuit parce que en fait le changement de
semaine tu avais tous ceux qui partait
de la première semaine
et moi je faisais les deux semaines je
me suis retrouvé tout seul dans le
dortoir et une heure du matin j'entends
c'est comme thriller est là elle est
prise et j'ai berbère
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est les 5 embrouiller mais
non voyons nous vous avez quel âge
ah ouais vous avez quel âge avait
c'est émilie la mono la cage 22-23 nuit
comme ça j'étais le seul de l'autre côté
alors non elle est rentrée dans l'ordre
tirent leurs revenus comment ça allait
se coucher à côté de mon nom c'est un
peu comme deux fines et ce quand il a
personnellement et dans son lit je suis
heureuse vous connaissez pas nous
embrouiller que de finir là c'est pas la
grande vadrouille là on va se calmer je
te promets donc elle est venue s'asseoir
à côté vous qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
pas si elle s'est allongée et prs
qu'elle a fait elle a fait elle a pris
les choses en mains d'une seule main
[Rires]
qu'il n'avait pas le bon avocat et la
rsr
et donc elle vous a mis tout nu voilà
sans aucun doute voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez c'est à prendre ou à laisser ouais
il appelle jo des boîtes je prends de la
vente de ces vrais et lui ait pas été le
maillon faible
alors qui a fait ça alors là dans sa
chambre c'est bien dans sa chambre tout
sonne dans sa chance côté ça dans ta
chambre euros thierry modo gilles verdez
enora et nora dans votre chambre mais
quelquefois avec les parents à côté non
il n'était pas là c'est un mercredi
après-midi
abbas était mairie mercredi après midi
au lieu d au lieu de regarder le club
non mais non c'était crime peut sinon
c'est un peu j'avais 17 ans c'était
génial c'est avec mon premier amour il y
avait des bougies c'est trop bien c'est
devenu mon meilleur ami alors là ça fait
rire personne
il y avait des bougies parce qu'au
départ ils étaient partis sur une séance
de spiritisme être quelque chose qui
faisait bouger la table et non c'est pas
les esprits sais c'est pas là
ok là
je veux les esprits chalet lancer mon
physique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon pour l'image il a redit la
chine en tout cas ça a l'air très beau
les bougies tout ça vous avez gardé les
bougies ouais j'ai gardé le meilleur ami
il est musicien génial
j'étais tellement c'est vrai ouais bon
c'est fort
j'avais offert pour son mariage il est
bon à léogâne qui a fait ça dans un
champ alors dans un saut en avant vers
déjà mené quoi on se tirait vous
détiendrez gilou qui arrivèrent des mois
jeudi gilles moi j'y ai ma claque dans
le bel été qui l'a placé à la fête du
collège mort la mort ou alors c'est le
bourreau alors vous allez dire que c'est
lui moreau à la fête du collège c'est
vrai oui alors là ça dépasse en fait
j'étais au lycée
mais en fait j'avais une fête dans un
collège désaffecté à côté du lycée et
j'adore et le diovan la fête du collège
de base il paraît qu'il ya deux
correspondants qui sont morts là bas ou
sur des correspondants espagnols je ne
parlais pas un mot d'espagnol ce que je
faisais allemand elle parlait pas un mot
de français je ne connais pas son prénom
je n'ai jamais revu et voilà ce que tu
lui dis en fait rien déconseillé
d'accepter un truc s'écrit cosafa paie
la note ne voit pas qu'elle vous avez
fait réalité qu'est ce que vous faites
pour la nuit
bref seule chose réelle à lui attirer la
lui a répété elle a alors répondu
tortillas il a dit c'est bon je n'ai
apprécié du problème espagne et de lui
explique je sais pas respectueux elle a
craqué sur vous sur le physique
bah oui c'est possible sur ces titres et
pierre perret un franc succès bah ouais
et alors que ça fait comment mais je ne
sais pas cru bon concept d'abord arrêter
de me suivre les jours des gens bon sens
mais non je ne les ai jamais revus dans
le lendemain les parties
et bien et là ce soir non mais c'est
vrai j'ai même donné à photo da la prod
delà du du collège ça s'est passé et on
s'en fou de voir le collègue nous on
veut voir la bague au doigt les collèges
super et gilles verdez ça s'est passé
dans un champ gilles verdez je suis pas
pour elle je la sens bien cette affaire
là ouais ouais il a dit que la première
fois pour lui c'était dans un champ vous
êtes habillé comme ça non mais ça s'est
pas bien passé en fait ce que le
problème c'est que c'était dans un champ
mais je suis allergique au pollen
moussaoui donc j'y arrivais pas alors
j'étais occupé et je j'ai terminé tout
sourire quoi lavables et alors et donc
ça a foiré donc du coup de rein school
est paca s'était dégradée en plus
c'était vraiment des salles graminées et
le blé j'étais super allergiques et
j'arrivais pas qu'on va arriver voilà on
avait compris d'accord merci aux
castings bien belles vagues la belle
histoire
ça fait rêver tous les jeunes qu'ils ont
[Musique]